yeah hello and welcome to this video
playing Thomas tell us here and I'm
going to faint careful and then see what
happens this is not a bad policy by the
way pretty decent opening choice just
cancelling and then see what happens
it's kind of decent against almost
anything ok so here Thomas Tallis is out
for be five that's probably not the most
precise move over here right at a plate
he gets be far then okay not much that I
can do this is just solid with nothing
special yeah I had a similar position
with colored reversed not too long ago I
mean okay roughly two and a half years
ago and back then I was quite happy to
just trade down and play against the sea
pawn I mean that position was with
colors reversed that should be mentioned
so what was the same kind of situation
situation but I had black and they had
exactly the same position as wide has
now here so let's see I would play the
same kind of strategy it is not an
advantage for white him yeah probably
maybe create for wasn't precise not
quite sure about it yeah it seems right
that he doesn't mind to trade but i have
to say i also don't mind I feel like
trades generally are quite okay in the
sea pawn is something that I can at
least attack
so is he playing me five no I don't
think so much that doesn't feel like it
lets much I mean he can't do that it's
not like it's terrible but nothing that
i need to i feel um prevent or be too
concerned about each 16th yeah probably
he feels that the back rank needs some
protection okay I'm getting out of the
checks if he goes before I think d 4 is
interesting using this pressure on the C
file yeah he still plated yeah he has
like d43 that that could be something
something something unclear that same
yeah that sets okay fine actually d 4 is
3 yeah I have to take a look takes
politics c5 and 26 and it looks like it
should be okay for him I don't like this
position all that much oh ok and this is
quite more let's go I have absolutely
nothing in
I always you never know you can always
play for some technical some more
technical things but it's difficult him
[Music]
we black is also much better here he has
the three against two but is not easily
include good sorry not easily moving
those pawns and young queen is three
books is sex he might be moving the
spawns
hmm how do I play that him
I don't see anything great relief I
wasn't really paying much attention to
see for here but he might might play it
right I mean something like c4 quindi
for is probably still equal but um yeah
it's so kind of annoying him you know
now i think i'm going to centralize here
prevents you for it still I cannot do
anything here threatening to take it out
he pushes it
yeah yeah I guess he gets the two looks
they are in this position so context
yeah roxy foxy form snot not that
gradient she takes on c1 King g21
probably be okay yeah I mean I don't
have a problem there I think but I'm
also not better yet probably I'm I
cannot be better yourself I'm just going
to do it ok tries to keep that ok you
might try to try to look at six you
cannot play I blunders to see to work
check and check only for so and it's not
moving the hooks easily cannot try to
page with you to create queen is always
going to be a new symptom time work okay
okay
if you really want to step into that
sales pinned down I had probably still
okay class it's still okay if f 2 is
hanging and it's in comfort
uncomfortable look at six of the good
move I guess before you can take it to I
have to go have to do that do it girl
check yeah let's not particular great 50
seconds yeah I wonder if this is a draw
or a lot would seem I I couldn't really
do much else I felt something like f5 my
people the line here it takes to X King
III kingi for King everywhere it's got a
very active position this I don't think
it should post that much of a problem I
no no no it actually does actually does
look right what is he doing
can you hooking a 16-gauge 5 cannot do
anything here really okay so we have a
draw draw altered gain throne hmm kind
of a draw run of drawers yeah not too
excited about all that him where's my
view and that is you I mean the engine
probably won't tell anything too
exciting but still yeah one key a key
moment was here when you played before I
intended to do this but it really seems
to be perfectly fine now the engine
agrees something like this I saw and
fill out this cannot be good for me my
king is really unsafe and two hangs i
know i saw that was but i couldn't quite
I didn't like the position simply so I I
took and played III which is probably
just equal yeah this is an interesting
as it is interesting try it for black to
file I think it probably should be a
draw but I have two ladies might might
have been wrong actually okay yeah yeah
do this query critical it might be a
draw might be a loss am I think the
engines this 10 so probably it is a draw
the way it's was played out a failed is
I guess I get a 5 at the end I can the
computer line but it's still wrong yeah
it was a very Jewish kind of game there
what um Garrett um sometimes happening
on the opening if you and I'll probably
that fall into the most precise move
over here right maybe clear night a
three or something Oh Lucy to I know I
don't don't regularly play this precise
move over here with white ok guys thanks
for watching